the connection between these objects and
phenomena okay alright hi everyone good
morning and thank you all for coming and
thank you to the organizers for inviting
me to speak so today I'll be talking
about as Jen said sort of connections
between polynomials high dimensional
expanders and sort of some of their
algorithmic applications in particular
to approximate counting problems okay
based on joint work with Cheyenne Newman
re and then Cynthia
so what are the objects that we're going
to study or study made towards which
we've seen throughout the week
I think versus our dealer yesterday even
gave like I think five or ten different
definitions of gait roids all with like
sort of their own usefulness and
geometric beauty but today we'll sort of
focus on like one specific definition
which is sort of like this simplicial
complex definition so what is a matriod
you're given a ground stitch you're
given a collection of subsets of this
ground set and this this collection the
elements of this collection called the
independent sets and they satisfy two
axioms namely that any subset of an
independent set is independent and that
they also satisfy an exchange axiom
namely that if you have two independent
sets one is larger than the other and
you can take an element from the larger
one and add and sort of augment the
smaller one and preserve independence
sort of and we'll call the maximal
independent sets the basis and by the
exchange property the basis all have the
same size which we call the rank and
I'll use R to denote the rank so to sort
of I guess classic example said maybe
you can keep in mind is sort of at the
graphic may trade which is where their
ground set are all edges of some graph
and then you have the collection of a
collection of edges it's independent if
and only if it does not contain a cycle
and then another example which is sort
of yeah another example would be say the
linear matrix where your ground set a
bunch of vectors and then subsets are
independent if only if they are linearly
independent okay so here in the graphic
case the basis of the spanning trees of
your graph and then the in the linear
case the basis are I guess your linear
basis or
so what is the problem that we're gonna
study or we're gonna study you're given
a Maitre and you want to estimate the
number of bases of the photograph of
your mate roid and how is the matrix
given to your basically you're given say
some function this is you can ask this
function whether or not say a given
subset it's independent that's how
you're given this matrix ort of like an
implicit and compact representation so
it's known as sharp be hard to do
exactly and it's even known that you
know to do use efficient deterministic
algorithms so you cannot obtain some
exponential approximation factor so
resolving is can you get say 1 plus
Epsilon efficiently using randomized
algorithms
so why should you care about this
problem so I guess one example it comes
from coding theory so here the setting
is you have say a parity check matrix
and the kernel this matrix gives all the
code words in your code and let's say
you send these code words through some
channel some noisy channel in which say
some bits might become corrupted and it
gets worse and you want it and your goal
is to be able to recover from these
errors so you can exactly recover from
these errors if and only if if you you
know when you send your codeword through
the channel the bits that get erased the
corresponding columns and your parity
check matrix are linearly independent
right because then you can just solve a
linear system to recover the bits so in
particular for example in this case if
you can count say the basis of a may
trade so in this case the match would be
the linear made sure given by the
columns of your of your parity check
matrix if you can count the basis of
this major then you can say for example
estimate that probability that your
you'll be able to recover from such an
error gives you a way to evaluate like
how are useful in some sense your codes
another example is from saying our
reliability here the setting is that say
you have some network some communication
network represented as a graph the links
is the edges correspond to links between
say servers in your network and say each
link fails independently with some
probability P and what you want to do is
they ask me the probability that your
graph becomes distracted and is that it
turns out they ask me its probability
you can do this exactly by counting the
basis of size and so I guess the third
application that maybe Paul is carabao
is sort of the state of the say uniform
distribution over the set of random
spanning forests trees
so they're sort of been there's been
many many many previous works so already
even just in the graphic case for
sampling random spanning trees or
counting random spent or accounting
spanning trees there also many many
works that sort of extend the graphic
case to other classes of matrices and
there are some other problems say in the
determinantal point process literature
where you can also cast this as a
counting or a sampling problem of basis
matrix Ted you wait you kind of wait to
do bases and more and I apologize if I
this this probably incomplete
so what is our main result I mean Rizal
is that yes indeed that there is a
polynomial time randomized approximation
algorithm that gives you a 1 plus or
minus epsilon multiplicative
approximation let's just recall that
sort of the applications of this are
just like cover from ratios in a linear
codes or a spanning graph liability or
random forest errors
okay so I guess our first step towards
like counting number bases is to reduce
this to a sampling problem okay so
called the promised estimate number
bases
let's crypt be the it's sort of the set
up all the collection of all bases of
your mates would
okay let's M so /e note the contraction
of your nature so this is the major it
given by you look at all independent
sets of your original image would you
take you've only keep the independent
sets which contain your element E and
then you remove it from them this is a
smaller Metroid called the contraction
okay now what you can do is you can
write the number of bases of the
original Metroid as so this telescoping
product and we observe is that sort of
each term in this product is a marginal
probability of some elements being in a
random base of some matrix sort of it
suffice it to estimate these marginal
probabilities and you just compute this
product how did it how Destinee these
probabilities you can just this is sort
of how you reduce their pocket sampling
if you can fortunately sample then you
just sample base see if your element is
in the base and just keep cycling and to
get better better estimates of your
marginal probability
so now we reduced it to a sampling
problem so our approach will be by a
Markov chains and what you have to do
for the Markov chain yer defined sort of
a graph on which you will do your random
walk okay and this random walk will be
the what we call the basis exchange
graph okay
so is this graph you're given a matrices
of this graph the state space
corresponds to all basis of your mate
royde and you have an edge between two
bases if and only if they intersect in
independent set of size rank minus one
we have two graphs here I draw two
spanning trees these two span trees are
adjacent each other to each other in
this graph and the space is exchange
graph because you just exchanged the
blue edge for the green edge this is
like a local update local move between
faces I guess a more concrete geometric
example would be this graph so this
comes from if you look at the partition
may trade on okay so I guess just one
way to say you have n bins each bin you
have say two options you have like a
blue ball or red ball and you're allowed
to choose at most one ball from each of
your n bins okay like blue or red okay
and now you can encode and your bases
are exactly when you choose exactly one
ball from each bin and so you can code
this as a bit vector and then two bases
are adjacent if only if they just differ
by like which ball you choose in one bin
so you can put these vectors and this
gives the basic the corresponding basis
exchange ref is exactly the hypercube
I've sort of defined what what graph
we're gonna do our random walk on let's
just let's write let's write out the
algorithm most explicitly step by step
so you start at a base okay any base you
want you could be deterministic just
pick a base you throw out a you flew in
Wrentham element and then you transition
so you start the base you threw out
uniform an element so this gives you a
size rank minus one independent set and
out of all bases that continue you pick
a uniform random one in transition to it
and we will capture the transition
probabilities of this of this this these
steps by this matrix P R of down up so
down up is to signify that we first
threw out an element and you come back
up complete or just do an example so
here I have the uniform a trade on rank
three on four elements okay and on the
right here at the table so you can think
of a Markov chain as every time step you
have a distribution over all possible
bases that you could be at at that time
step and then when you every time you
take a step in the Markov chain you're
evolving this distribution so here I
start at one two three four or I went to
three four one two four okay look at all
I guess well I'll call these are near
bases some independent sets of size rank
-1 look at all new bases that are
underneath my picture you another one I
transition to it a base that contains me
so you see that the this is the
distribution on possible basis you could
be at a given time step is evolving is
this possible
I know that you can return to the same
base that you were at before
so and you sort of noticed that these
probabilities are evening out and that's
that's actually what we want let's do
our goal is so in the end for this thing
to converge in some sense to the uniform
distribution over all phases
so I would tell you what convergence
means so let's first define a metric on
probability distributions this is where
so a very common probably distribution
is the total variation distance which is
sort of if you can think of us just to
the maximum discrepancy that two
probably is the probability
distributions can take on any table and
we can find a mixing time as just the
minimum of time it takes for your Markov
chain distribution to say be epsilon
close to uniform
and it's sort of a well known fact that
you can bound the mixing time you can
upper bound the mixing time by the
inverse spectral gap of your transition
probability matrix times the logarithmic
factor like log of one over epsilon and
log of the the size of your state space
okay so in this case this logarithm
logarithmic factor is okay because the
size the number of bases that most n to
the power R so sort of the main thing we
have to do is so upper bound this
inverse a or in other words found the
second largest eigenvalue of the
transition polymatrix away from one will
do what will prove is that you can bound
it away from one by one over r
and this immediately implies sort of
what we want to show which is that there
is this polynomial time randomized
algorithm and also it actually also
implies that the spaces exchange graph
has this combinatorial property of
having edge expansion at least one
we'll be on this
okay so at this point let me sort of
belief you recall some of the always
talked about yesterday so our approach
is based off of what professor Kaufman
impressed our Oppenheim talked about
yesterday okay let me just sort of
really go through it again at a high
level okay so what is the idea the idea
is to prove this bound inductively
tactically so first you reduce it to
that I mention our minus one okay so how
do you do this so recall that the way
that we laid out this algorithm is
you've started at the base you throw out
a random element and you come back up
okay so you can think about this as sort
of first you have this Markov chain on
the bipartite graph between near bases
and bases where you have an air base is
connected to a base if only the near
base is contained in the base and then
the walk that we're interested in is
just given by you start at the base and
you take two steps each time inside this
bipartite watch okay so this by part I
walk induces induces the random walk
that we're interested in by taking two
steps
but what you can do is also you can say
that okay I can all start an ear base
take two steps go up and come back down
okay
and so this induces some random walk on
also near bases
and these two random acts are very much
related so if you look at the transition
probability matrix ease
they're both self adjoint with respect
to some inner product they both have
positive or non-negative eigenvalues and
particularly the most important thing
for us is that they have the same
nonzero eigenvalues with multiplicity
and so if we want to bound the second
largest eigenvalue of our the transition
probably matrix that were interested in
suffice it to pound the second largest
eigenvalue of this the random walk
defined on near bases
so let's go down dimension once more
so I do originally we had this bipartite
graph between ear basis in bases where
we could have done the same construction
between size rank - two independent sets
in size rank - one independent sets okay
so we could have defined for example of
the down up walk can we sit down the up
down walk okay
so here the so we have this so okay so
now I'm particular we have two random
walks on near basis okay sighs Frank -
one independence that's one given by you
first go up to a base and you come back
down and then the other given by you go
down to a size Frank - two independent
set I didn't come back up
and so the keep the induction going well
with what we have to do is to relate
these two chains as well okay they have
the same state space and in particular
they have the same station or
description okay the sort of way you
have to get that is story you have to
wait if the way to the your independent
sets and the way to give them is
proportional to the probability that you
see this independent set when you sample
you know from the render base or you
think of this proportional to the number
of bases that continue so this one makes
all the wood waste consistent and this
base ensures that it induces the same
data station or distribution and all all
all infinite sets
it's sort of the main thing we have to
do is prove a relation with them between
them and this is the relation
and again I emphasize that we could have
done this whole thing not just at the
top level or dimension R minus one or
dimension R - ooh but at all levels of
the matrices to have dimension K or rank
K where you define a bipartite walk
between in the exercise K independent
eyes sets of size K minus 1 by Friday
walk take two steps to induce random
walks on independent set of size K and
independent sets of a size K minus 1 and
so on so the more general statement of
anything about groove is no rules for
all dimensions
these weights are induced by the wheels
right they're not something here in car
outside so I mean so at the top level
right we want uniform dispersion of all
of our bases so they are induced by that
distribution
okay so forth anymore let's to say that
let's to see how if you have this you
have that number then you can exactly
get the bound you want just by
unraveling the recursion just just doing
the induction and bounding from some
bottom at the top
so
most this relationship this is sort of
where the the machinery of the Kauffman
Oppenheim theory so they they introduce
high dimension expanders but let me just
sort of recall the setting there okay so
the setting is is you have a simplicial
complex so what is the simplest
república simply for companies is I
think of as a generalization of a graph
okay if you have a set system you again
it's downwards closed where if an
element in a set system a subset of that
element then that subsets also in your
set system so note that in particular
matrix are simplicial complexes okay
with so major it's our separate comics
with an added property of exchange here
I drew the central complex again for the
uniform a trade on for elements of rank
three twelve operations that we will be
needing which we've hoped we recall from
yesterday would be one of them will be
the link so link is you just think of it
as follows or you you pick some say
reference element in your complex and
what it what the link is is a simplicial
sub complex given by you take all of the
faces that contain your reference face
and then only those and you remove your
reference face bump okay so so it more
explicitly so note that in particular
for example if you take a link of your
complex with respect to the empty set
this gives you your complex back and
also for people for major theorists link
another way to say the link is also the
contraction
very explicit
let's say we're taking the link with
respect to the single 10 3 you take all
of the faces above it that contain it so
this is level 1 above a little 1 higher
these are the only faces that you keep
so you throw out everything else and now
every face contains 3 so let's just
remove 3 from it this is redundant
so the next operation that we're needing
is also the one skeleton
and this is simply just you have a
simply for complex you only look at the
size one and size two elements of your
this gives you a graph so so for example
here we just have the vertices and the
edges throw out everything else and then
these edges are what connect your
vertices
okay so now having sort of set up the
definitions that we'll need now let's
talk about high dimensional expanders so
what is that we want to do we know that
in sort of the world of grass we know
that if you have expansion then this
immediately gives you rapid mixing of
the random walk on your breath sort of
what you want to do is the same thing
here so i dimension expander then you
want to say that the global random walk
is also epidemic seen so let me say that
for example the the the global walks
that I described earlier on matrix can
be said in full generality for any
simplicial complex this is exactly what
the Kauffman Kauffman Oppenheim theory
gives us so let's first let's make
precise what we mean by high dimensional
expansion okay so we we use a local
criterion which is sometimes easier to
verify so what do we want we want that
for every link which you think of maybe
as localizing your complex if you look
at the graph that you get from that link
this graph is a good expander in the
usual graph sense
so yeah let me sort of say some of the
maybe some intuition and that Professor
oka Kaufmann mentioned yesterday so why
and why this definition so maybe here's
some some intuition which is suppose
let's say you're looking at the global
random walk or at the global graph of
all size K elements of your solution
looks okay and you want to say that this
thing is a this graph is a good expander
let's say let's just take two elements
tau and Sigma okay and I say there there
is a match so we assume the suppressor
complex is connected but sort of what we
wanted in the end is that this is very
well connected so let's say that there's
some tension there okay
so you look at their intersection this
gives you a element of one dimension
less and we're just sort of saying that
so let's say and I'd say that their
intersection is containing some other
elements so what you're saying that is
that if so this is the link if this link
is a good it's a good expander graph
then what it should in some sense
enforce is that there should be some
other edges it also across this cut
the local expansion sure you should have
at least some more than just one
so they proved is that we have this
relationship between the global random
walk on level K going up down and the go
around over random walk on live okay
going so recall that what we actually
wanted is the following so it's a Feist
is to take what we want is to say that
okay we have lambda equals zero for our
for our problem
so our goal is to show that mate roads
are zero local spectral expanders
so sort of the prove this what we'll do
is we'll in storage now introduce
polynomials into the picture and we'll
see how properties of polynomials
translate to properties or local
properties of our simplicial complex
okay so fill up this mapping so let's
first see how if you got a simplicial
complex you can go to a polynomial okay
so if you have a simpler complex I'll
define a sort of a generating polynomial
for its maximal faces but I just get a
variable for each element of your ground
sit and then you sum over all maximal
faces of your simplicial complex and
take the product of the variables of the
corresponding elements in that in those
faces
well here so here let's just we have a
graph let's look at the graphic matric
of it so that the elements of our ground
set are the edges of this graph let's
give them some labels so 184 so now
we'll have variable Z 1 Z 2 Z 3 Z 4 and
for this graph we have the basis of this
major are just the spanning trees of the
graph so we have three spanning trees
here
each spanning tree gives us a monomial
in our polynomial and so now it's added
up and that's exactly our generator
and you also go the other way so if you
haven't if you have polynomial okay the
oldest integer complex in the same way
so you have a polynomial you take each
mono each variable corresponds to an
element of your ground set each monomial
corresponds to maximum face of your
central complex
so for example here we have just this
polynomial you get an element or a
vertex of your special complex for each
variable you get a maximum phase for
each monomial and then you just take
downwards closure and you get everything
in between
so sort of now we have this
correspondence between simpler complexes
and well this let's build up sort of a
dictionary of map mapping concepts from
simpler complexes to concepts from
polynomials okay cool I guess dr.
difficulty just the dimension of the
complex is just equal to the degree of
your polynomial the purity of your
complexes corresponds to how much an ad
of your polynomial some one more
interestingly is that if you say look at
the number of maximal faces this
corresponds to be evaluating your
polynomial at all once okay and
particularly can cast the goal of
counting two and more generally as a
problem of evaluate in your polynomial
this is clear so again we have the same
graphic mate would we have three
spanning trees here it's the polynomial
if you evaluate all the ones you get
exactly three monomials
another nice sort of correspondence is
that the operation of sort of localizing
your complex by taking link corresponds
to differentiating your polynomial
so let's see that in action here again
so we have the graphic matriod for this
graph we have these three spanning trees
and we have the corresponding generating
polynomial okay so let's sort of take a
link with respect to one the edge one so
since every span tree contains one you
just get them and oh no 4 everything
stays and you just take out edge
it's an example is sick if you want to
say differentiate with respect to say z2
they just contract this edge because you
always want that in your spanning tree
and since this one does not contain two
then that's not allowed and we are only
left with monomials corresponding to the
spanning trees of the contracted graph
and so putting these two together you
can see that also that so here the
numerator is just you could take the
partial derivative with respect to say
some element and you value all once this
gives you all bases that contain your
element and in the denominator you just
get all bases so in particular this is
the marginal probability of seeing your
element in a uniformly random base
and so final more most interesting thing
is that is the weighted adjacency matrix
of your skeleton is corresponds to the
Hessian here oh no I just compute the
Hessian it just sort of follows from
previous items in our dictionary
yes you sort of think that maybe on the
attend side you have a sort of oil
perspective the right-hand side you have
sort of morality per se
okay so let's add one more entry into
this dictionary okay
so let's recall from yesterday sort of
lock on Kapaun numbers or lorenzi and
polynomials or I sort of give a lot of
nice they were used to for um approve a
lot of nice comment or inequalities and
we'll see that they are actual also very
useful here so this is recall that
eponymous lock on cavus the hessian the
logarithm is negative semi colon only
the hessian itself is bounded by this
rank 1 positive semi definite matrix
and what a strong lock in cavity this is
you you say upon is strong I'll cave
lock on cave if also every derivative is
la complete and we saw it yesterday I
think from your host auch tat every this
is this is equivalency the poem is
Lorenz en or the problem is completely
lock okay
and so the nice thing is that if you
have if you have la concavity then you
know that the Hessian has at most one
positive value like just because there's
my virtue of the fact that it's bounded
above by a rank one positive
semi-definite matrix so you can kind of
see that you have strong off in cavity
then what you're saying is that also
that every link the or every every
derivative the Hessian has endless one
positive light
so you also recall from them I think
Cynthia's talk or they also Jun has
talked we also know we now we know that
base is generating polynomial of any
matrix is from a concave or completely
la concave or lawrencium
so in particular yeah as I said earlier
the Hessian of every derivative has at
most one possibility
so particularly if you use our
dictionary that we saw earlier I'll
remind you on it sort of the next slide
you know that the second largest
eigenvalue of every localized random
walk matrix is bounded by zero okay so
particular this gives us exactly one
mate rates are zero local spectral
expanders
any questions so far
so let's just go back our dictionary and
now we can sort of add another entry to
our dictionary you see a zero a local
spectral expansion it's strong low
concavity
okay
so just a quick recap so so after all
this they sort of see that we have a
pollen time resident randomized
algorithm to produce a good
approximation of the number of basis of
an you may trade using Markov chain
this actually also works in the weighted
case so you can actually also way to
your bases and then what you would do to
weight all of independent sets lower is
just to save is to add up the weights of
all the bases that contain you
so I guess the more general theorem is
that if you give an Oracle access to the
coefficients of the strong law concave
polynomial
he's a you're allowed to ask for the
coefficient of a given monomial then you
can evaluate this polynomial actually at
any point in a positive or cent and give
1 plus 2 minus epsilon approximation to
it
I guess so there's some other there many
other applications beyond sort of what I
said being in the talk so for example
now you can account for us compute a
reliability polynomial it turns out that
also the the Q Potts model partition
function for Q between 0 & 1 is okay
this is also proof by eun-hye on paper
and then this actually also implies a
strong cavity of the Tut polynomial in a
certain regime and also we can get that
if you have a determinant of point
process that you can solve smooth the
weights by raising the coefficient it is
some
so I guess there's sort of many many
open problems left still so for example
we actually also met we know that I
think so this was mentioned I think a
Nima's talk at the boot camp that if you
have a strong Lila concave polynomial I
think it's also dimension in June has
talked as well you have a strong a lot
concave polynomial and you look at the
support if you look at all monomials
with nonzero coefficients these the
support has to form the basis of some
matrix so in particular when the sense
is sort of that all of the the mixing
time bounds that we have to only work
for case when your support form the
basis of nature to you but there are
many other combinatorial structures
beyond mate roads that
but yeah many other combinatorial
structures beyond make sure it's later
for example could you use some of this
machinery develop a cup and Oppenheim
and also polynomials to say something
about counting non broken bases or
counting proper colorings of a graph for
a
another question is that so so far what
I've showed you in the talk is that we
bound the second largest eigenvalue
but actually all over any qualities all
the inequalities I allow you to bound
every eigenvalue of probability matrix
okay so but so far we haven't used any
of those any of that information so I
guess another question would be could
you improve the mixing time if you use
leverage information about all the other
Agra dots and even eigenvectors or
so it's another question is can you get
mixing using approximate negative
correlation okay so what does that mean
so this this is just to write something
on the board
so negative correlation is essentially
the following inequality which says that
if you look at the probability of seeing
say an element in your ace your random
base condition on say some other element
being in your base this is less than or
equal to just if you had not seen f at
all this is called negative correlation
and sort of the the seminal work of
Federer me Heil
[Music]
all miners
so if you have negative coalition on
every contraction and a possible
sequence of contractions and deletions
we may join then you have mixing
tomorrow and the proof is also inductive
very similar induction but so the
problem is is that it's known so this is
the thing is that they satisfy something
like an approximate kind of negative
coalition which is observed
independently judo and Pater Brendon and
also by a Cheyenne City anima which is
that
so it's possible in the sense that you
have an extra factor of two yes
so what I'm asking here is that if you
can say maybe use this approximate form
a negative correlation to but coupled
with the same technique from credit me
how to get the same mixing
yes
now tiny did that website is the truth
so I have conjectured that it's eight
over seven
yeah there is an example achieving eight
over seven sequence of entrance just
limit the sight of the seven I am using
a tensions right right
my guess is that soft more independent
of the round independent of the right
for anything
I guess the last thing I mentioned is
that sort of the full you have odds are
and conjecture which is says that you
have any zero one polytope that's a the
vertices of your polytope have
coordinates with only zeros are once and
if you look at the skeleton the graph
obtained by just connecting vertices
that has else lady's edge expansion at
least one so we prove is that what we
proved earlier which is that form a toy
polytopes we have a edge expansion at
least one but so the full conjecture
4:01 polytopes is still open
this
is it 15 minutes of questions as I ended
much earlier than I expected
you know there's some cases where the
mixing time times you dead I are tight
well upset I think it's cases where the
mixing down time bounds you get all
right partner right so we think that we
can we can improve it so Francis and
we're sort of trying to see if maybe
they get rid of the square
is the sort of we sort of know so much
more information than just second
alright so you can actually bound all
eigenvalues so that you can bound
algorithms and there's a question of
pounding
dr. Funkenstein
some of the cuts that is the thing is
hypercube is tight so like any proof you
get here
yeah well I'm not that it not annexing
their eigenvalues are all right so you
have to Oh a reason is that this is
improving an ocular yeah so yeah the
thing is for I pick you like it's tricky
to get down like either you have to use
what type of expand
yeah I should probably mention Oh
yes we had three local special expansion
but so I guess I should comment that I
used to my knowledge the the people in
the high dimensional expander community
they want like it's like bounded degree
expanders is that and these are by
[Music]
but you see the collection it agrees
that most I think you agreed you mean
it's like number of like maximum face
that contains all one skeleton graph of
each link so we know that for example
you take the skeleton of an image that
is actually a complete multi-part type
graph so it's very very dense that's
what your ass but you don't get so our
complex is not complete right
like everywhere
[Music]
all right so let's say you have n
vertices and rank R they are dimension R
so I think from previous words of
Cheyenne NEMA and the Cynthia they have
this entropy inequality with actually
allows you to bound like lower bound the
number of bases are exponential it
depends on the marginal if your matrix
can have just one base but if it is like
that marginal of elements an example
that most what happens that's it
and it's basically said you cannot get
that it's parse expanders if you want
zero so like for your applications you
actually have to go above zero if you
want to get a sparse and is there any
way that your things
I'm not sure we go with the I guess the
analog of welcome cavity for we allow
larger than zero
but it's one thing if you have a
different language and we be able to put
things here
it's
yeah
Elsie's like simplify
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
because my my
Oh Oh No
yes I'll take a simple operation and
improves the vertex expansion
turn it into a ball